thank you
[Music]
so some JK fans sent this article uh
because they thought it was as
ridiculous as I did but there's this uh
blog site called koreaboo oh I don't
believe anything on that thing North
Korea really what are they known for
yeah
the name itself screams of k-pops fans
that has nothing but drama on their mind
and the occasional dopebookie recipe
podcast where Jackson Wang was a guest
Kendra's podcast hosted by Anthony Lee
yeah it was Anthony and uh and Ben Chung
aren't they aren't you guys like besties
and [__]
uh with Jackson Wings yeah he's in the
crew yeah can you just podcast is highly
edgy though they always like talk about
controversial talk yeah like how much
they didn't believe that 9 11 happened
and then I think we're making more
problems now oh are we well let's talk
about the article then so what happened
is uh Jackson was having a conversation
with Anthony and Ben about potential
marriage with
um someone who didn't want kids or
someone who did want kids and they're
all just talking about their differences
like a relationship friends having a
conversation and I think what this site
thought it was was that this was
journalists interviewing
a celebrity wow they freaking upgraded
you guys congrats that's dough I feel
like look at these [__] predatory
journalists trying to hurt our Jackson's
image so they think that upgraded them
based off their own autism
oh so they believe that like Anthony's
trying to influence Jackson that
Jackson's pushing back and they're
reading into this like like com almost
like an imaginative way where they feel
like there's some kind of a conflict or
a Discord happening when really English
[__] it's just homies talking
and homies are allowed to voice whatever
their opinion is without any fear that
they might be misinfluencing the other
person so in their minds this fool is
Pierce Morgan and Jackson Wang was
Andrew Tate and honestly to to be fair
if it was if it was like journalists
that don't know Jackson personally it is
a little bit weird for them to be
talking like that but that's not the
case yeah that's like me watching
physical 100 without subtitles on it
like they're just trying to have an orgy
with each other
that's exactly what is it yeah so I just
wanted to bring it up you can speak the
language you dumb [__] now that
Anthony's back I mean what the hell
happened here
um I mean again like Jackson's literally
like brothers with us like he's a part
of the Kansas crew like that's uh that's
already we preached you know familial
ties like it's beyond just like regular
friendship I think that we're very close
and connected but don't Brothers fight a
lot too absolutely and I think that's
totally okay and you know disagree a lot
too bringing somebody onto a podcast is
you know and the way that we're trying
to do it too is to have like open and
honest conversations that maybe aren't
like superficial maybe aren't things
that you might be comfortable having in
other random podcasts or interviews and
stuff like that it's a lot more it's
Unique yeah it's more intimate it's
supposed to be more real we're drinking
alcohol together and we're talking about
things that we've even talked about off
camera and we're like yo look because
you actually know each other yeah yeah
and I'll even say stuff like that I was
like hey you know like we were talking
about this like what's what's up with
your your love life why did you say that
you you had the toughest year of your
life like what makes you feel lonely you
brought that up let's talk about it and
the the beautiful thing about podcasts
is even with close friends sometimes you
don't sit down and have those
one-on-ones yeah yeah that's true
podcast gives you space and like a
purpose to like go deeper than a
superficial conversation what's up cam
that's also one thing cool about
podcasts you have friends just running
around like there are Kendra yeah yeah
um that being said uh
I believe that you know this particular
article is like taking like one line out
of context and I do think that it's a
touchy subject right like you know he's
talking about finding love finding a
partner
um she's talking about wanting to have
kids but then like understanding and
empathizing uh with women about how like
childbirth is such a hard experience so
he's willing to like just be like it's
up to her but and which is [__]
gentlemanly and that's great yeah you
know what I mean
um I said
I was like you know maybe like find a
wife that also wants kids
and I think that's the one coach
for saying that yeah so it sounds pretty
reasonable outrageous what was the
outrage show them the yeah can you read
it for me like pretty much find a
like-minded individual and then they
took it as you're like trying to force
your values on him yeah well
overly like Ryan's also seen the podcast
and stuff like that so you know it's
easier to dress like a third party's
like perspective because I I want to be
empathetic to like fans as well you know
what I mean mental diseases as this
journalist have I think I think I you
know what I think it is I think I think
it's a 19 year old girl and she's like
she doesn't get it
you know like she hasn't had these
conversations yet that's true because it
is past a certain like at a certain age
is when you start having these actual
conversations very simple where where
like Jackson's opinion about it is very
lauded it's like that's great that that
you will be willing to let your
potential you know dream wife decide if
she wants kids or not that's decisions
that's your decision that's really cool
yeah yeah yeah some people so people
want to know now before they choose
their partner if that's someone who
wants and that's
potentially a thing that could break you
up if you went into the relationship and
then all of a sudden you're like oh wait
you don't want kids and I do that's a
problem people they both want kids they
get together but one of them
biologically can't yeah but because the
other person still wants kids they break
up too and it could be the guy doesn't
want Katie to be the girl doesn't like
it would have to explain some of that
stuff later on in the podcast too
because we we're still talking about it
and I'm like I have very very close
friends that like they got married and
both of them understood that they wanted
children and then somebody somehow
changed their mind later and it's not
about right or wrong you know like in
one instance like the uh the the girl
she she just was like really wrapped up
in her career and didn't want to like
suddenly have a child and that would
like kind of like throw off her career
stuff it's like that's not wrong but
because of like where they were in life
they got divorced for it and it's like
you know if you have that conversation
at least try you know what I mean before
tying the knot to like have that
conversation that's something that's
like a very like you need this for your
life because you're going into a
contract with somebody that's like you
know so I'm explaining these things
because I've like seeing it happen in my
close circle of friends where like
people have gone through their own
heartbreaking tragedy because things
like that happen and I'm not saying it's
anybody's fault but that's why when this
guy's who is doesn't have a partner yet
is talking about saying he wants kids
but he's like oh you know but like I
want to I'm like dude that's amazing but
I'm like maybe there's a woman out there
who also wants kids at the very least
you know I mean that's like my stance
and that's great if your opinion's
malleable that's [__] convenient as
hell but the thing is I think what these
fans are doing is they're trying to
exalt his opinion as like that is the
best possible opinion and it is but you
don't have to make it look like his
opinion is the demon like it doesn't
necessarily create something evil on
that end but I think they want to just
protect the goodness of his opinion so
badly that they want to like showcase
that like oh even in the storm of
Anthony his opinion Jackson's opinion
prevails yeah and it's like got it he's
their hero yeah but then what else is it
done what was their uh what was their
counter or like what was their because
they're also they're making it sound
like Anthony's saying that before you
even engage in any rapport with a woman
you should make sure she's either
fertile or wants to have kids but I
gotta check if she's it's taking it to a
whole another level do you think um so
how do you check her ovaries before you
even start dating the app
I don't know so is this like um is this
like an American site or is it I don't
know
it's probably a website they're all
blue-haired white girls that love K-pop
that are writing on it so the reason why
I asked that's funny the reason why I
ask is because maybe the way that
they're seeing
you know men traditionally be he kind of
breaks out of that mold right because
traditionally at least Mexican too you
know you want to have someone that
you're gonna have kids with like it's
just expected that you get married and
you have kids traditionally
um so maybe for them they're like whoa
he's an Asian out or Asian male outlier
that's thinking even considering the
woman and then Here Comes this this uh
this this machismo or this like guy that
like is trying to like bring back
Vietnam and maybe they see him as like
is that what it might be happening they
see him as like like as a threat to a
very valued opinion yeah I think it's
much more simpler than that they're
protecting their husband Jackson
female simps that's all it is yeah it's
like can you see this [__] dirty
Vietnamese ass male chauvinist
evil face he thinks he's so cute
thinking he could influence the thoughts
of my powerful husband my biggest gripe
is that they're missing a really really
valuable point which is that Jackson
Wang is a celebrity that will be
interviewed a million times by a million
different people but only in this
particular podcast will you get people
honestly talking to him like a real
[__] person yeah I think that's the
big thing and they're getting an opinion
out of him that he wouldn't even
otherwise be able to to speak on so be
thankful that he's here talking to
Anthony who's willing to [__] say the
real questions yeah yeah but fans
want to control you they don't really
care about you as a human yeah most
stands and fans that are crazy they want
to mold this perfect Jackson in their
image and they want to preserve that and
if he asks any other way
that breaks that mold there's they'll
hate him which which is also hard for
like a celebrity because then it
pressures them to always need to do the
perfect thing yeah you know what I mean
yeah sir which is why like even as
because I I totally understand even with
what Geo said too like like I get it I'm
not saying that
by suggesting maybe find somebody like
that wants kids too like everybody in
the world needs to agree with one thing
it's more like my friend who's sitting
across from me says he wants kids it's
like oh this is next part of the
conversation here's a statement that
like continues the conversation like
where does that go where does your
belief go after that that's like what a
podcast does right you like break down
different things and I too can sit there
and learn something new you know what I
mean even though you're being uh Curious
exactly you know it's it's meant to be a
conversation but
um just for context too
uh obviously like people were like
messaging me saying that I was getting
like [__] destroyed on Twitter being
called a massages all these different
things like a couple fans or pretty
former fans were talking about how they
lost all fans [__] for me people are
commenting on our YouTube video and just
saying oh [__] up things you know wow
but it is what it is but like you know I
I was talking with Jackson on the side
and he was like yo what the [__] and he
asked me and he's such a [__] great
guy he's like yo what do you want to do
about it and I kept it real with them I
was I was and he's like uh he was super
like [__] great guy he was like what
do you want to do about it and first and
foremost like I'm sorry I put you
through this and whatever experience
you're going through I just want to know
how you're feeling I was like Yo dude
like I'm gonna keep it real with you
like off top like number one it was
upsetting to like experience that but
then number two like it's it doesn't
actually matter in the end I too like
went through that same experience with
you we sat down and had that
conversation if I put on any views or
perspectives or opinions that made you
feel uncomfortable or anything I also
apologize like that's not the point you
know like what what were Dylan is having
a conversation as boys and looking out
for each other and he's like what do you
want to do for about it and I was like
look I understand your position
you don't have to do anything I'm not
asking you to do anything you're gonna
shout me out maybe two or three times
yeah yeah give me some tickets next door
you could have wrote on Twitter like
shut up you dumb [__] yeah what I
would never I would never why did you do
that for me Jackson actually ironically
I was like you know in my maybe it's
because I was subconsciously like even
being a choreographer for him like my
kind of Base goal has always been to
make him look good I'm like I still feel
like we succeeded you came on here of
course like my class or whatever it's
like you still look great I'm not mad at
like what the overall outcome is but
like as long as me and you are cool we
understand each other it's like I'm good
with it because it's gonna come it's a
podcast like it's not meant for
everybody that hive mind and always
agree can't agree with everybody you
know what I mean but I know what we were
talking about with each other I know
where the intention and the care comes
from and if we understand that then it's
like you know what whatever comes will
come and for what it's worth Anthony I
don't think you're a massage
he's a chauvinist not a misogynist dude
there's a difference
that you're either
thank you I think you're quite a
gentleman no but then you rolled your
eyes at me so I'm second guessing
I will say you know like especially when
you feel that when you feel a judgment
from like a bunch of people or people
even like that once for your fan and
stuff it does kind of put you in a spot
where you have to like second guess
things but you know even being like in
the text thread and Ryan bringing it up
and just being like yo this is [__]
you know it
kind of like
at least like
as a friend just makes you feel better
as like a human yeah because it's like
the real people that know you yeah know
that it's [__] because you do kind
of start questioning I'm like oh well
I'm like on social media and a bunch of
different people are like calling me
this or that and you're like oh [__]
like at the end of the day this has an
effect on you and I can only imagine
what somebody like Jackson oh yeah you
know what I mean might also go through
because so many people influence your
everyday being and you have to like
conscious like constantly be grounded
enough in who you actually are to stand
by your own values before you get swept
by like what you think you need to do to
appease and approve everybody you know
what I mean so it does get crazy but it
was fortunate enough to to have close
friends to be like no like this is crazy
to make you stand by things that you at
least believe about yourself and I think
that's really important because that's
the point of the podcast to speak your
truths even if it's not perfect yeah
that's what makes it a good thing and
that's why I feel like if you're a fan
of Jackson just be glad that he has an
environment and a safe space where he
can say what he thinks and these guys
aren't going to misconstrue it and you
can look at what he said and pick that
as the thing you want to stand by but
again he's not being influenced by
Anthony in a negative way yeah they're
speaking to each other
he has no ability to do that I did say
immediately though I was like kind of
low-key this is why Jackson can't come
on JK news because if you can't [__]
survive J like hinge's podcast the fans
would be [__] if he came I would want
to see those [__] fans come on our
comments and dude they'll get roasted
that's as a person who's been canceled
six times or more that's a special Club
the wonderful thing about it is it
exposes the stupid ones that weren't
really your fans in the first place
they're like I can't believe you I'm
leaving I thought you would give me it's
like dude that's why the fans we have
now it's the best [__] era ever yeah
because we weeded out all the stupidest
people that were following us for the
wrong reasons right like everybody that
left when we made fun of The Dalai Lama
people left after that no that's the
joke basically because we we said we
didn't like that the Dalai Lama told the
kid to suck his tongue but then all
these uh what is it called
what are they Tibetans Tibetans all
these Tibetans [__] flooded the Inbox
and be like I'm so disappointed but none
of them have followed none of them have
any previous messages with the DMS they
literally came in to act like they were
fans to say they're leaving wow lose
anything they were you they weren't even
following our Instagram it's like all
these people that come in and talk [__]
during these times like eh
anymore it's like well you weren't even
like really a follower in the first and
we maintained that like dude he's a
global figure he has to be held to
Global standards like it doesn't matter
if your culture says that that's cool
yeah like my culture thinks balut is
cool don't you know you don't gotta eat
it yeah you know but anyway with the
Jackson thing I think the fans you guys
should be thankful that uh that Jackson
has friends that he's comfortable enough
with that you might get an exclusive
opinion he won't share anyway you guys
should watch the kinjaz podcast with
Jackson Wang because I didn't watch it
but I'm sure because I was on it
personally I know how it goes down
and it does get very intimate and real
it's not a stupid [__] news like
episode where everything's like so
what's happening in your new album oh
I'm coming out with a great album you
know what I mean like [__] that and to
keep it as simple as if you love Jackson
Jackson loves [__] Anthony
love this guy and Anthony loves his Wang
oh
my God